i want to die i want to freeze to death
i'm sorry what
[Music]
hey hi you
[ __ ] unquenchable thirsty
[ __ ]
every week you needed another one it's
not enough
70 [ __ ] 100 weeks in a row
he's [ __ ] unslackable
thirsty get him get him hold on
hold on i'm no i'm sick of this
this is mike on uh hi everyone hi
how are you um
we did up when you tell me about your
week be honest no you told me about
yours
well what did i i did the kevin i
finished up to kevin
finish kev um
and did you just chill after that
no beyonce in my line of work there is
no challenge
uh no i didn't tell i have to do i i
there's another
thing yeah the thing with him so i've
just been working on that oh double time
kevin this week
a lot of kevin ptk well i learned
something interesting which is when you
me and cat friend of the show cat who
may show up later on
um we were
it's interesting to see what if you
google your name what
the searches are like
neil brennan it's you'll also be feet
every woman's feet
maybe at the bottom yeah there you go
net worth three mics
kevin hart oh got into it bianca
and neil brennan daughter daughter who
is
hopefully people think you are my
daughter
it's chelsea
that's very funny so yeah what does it
say your net worth is is it
accurate just joking don't answer that
it says five million dollars
is that totally wild no idea
i don't i don't like to get involved
anyhow i bring that up oh that kevin has
broken into my
my google what's your imdb star meter
that i can't get into
i don't i don't don't do that i don't
care about it i'm joking um
but that kevin's broken in as a it was a
lot of chase commercial
kevin hart i think people want to know
if we were really neighbors from the
chase commercial
no yeah people ask me on twitter are you
guys really neighbors
are you serious yeah yes and we live on
the
american beauty street where we shot the
commercial
uh did that and
then look at all the people you're
connected to
dave charlie bird
it's just only people from youtube um
the uh so that was interesting for some
reason to me i don't know why i brought
that up
it's just constant connection i did
three spots on saturday night
where outside okay
i've never done work i've done two
virtuals awful awful
awful is you i think you described it as
your nightmare
it's my nightmare it felt like
suffocating i've had bad
ayahuasca trips better than virtual
stand-up shows
uh just a nightmare so
but it looks like we won't have to do
those anymore bye
person that like what do you think all
these virtual
sets and people who invested so much i
mean
i think they're gonna it's gonna be
uh go to grad school
i think you take what you learned and
you go to grad school okay
and or you turn it into something for
like bar mitzvahs or
kids or you know what i mean like this
is something something
well by the way a lot of the world still
has a lot of covet
so true um we'll get into that
right there um and
anyhow so you don't remember your week i
just
it's we i like i i don't know why it's a
huge blank to me
every it's only a blink when you ask me
though
midway through the podcast i remember
great let us know
um did you see about the george floyd
verdict
i did it
yeah oh they hadn't released it they
haven't dropped it they didn't drop it
um well the thing that we talked about
uh with about that the
sense i got was
black people seem to be like okay
like happy but very qualified or like
sad whatever like not whatever it was it
wasn't a hundred percent like
well hooray i think it's
i don't think i don't think it's ever
going to be o.j
again you know also
right we just have too many discussions
we know too much now
it's just like uh okay was a perfect
storm
oh it was a problem meaning it was like
killed a white lady got away with it
it's [ __ ] hilarious and great don't
say
death is hilarious i write letters um
only talk about slavery and other stuff
that i think is funny
somehow um this was a guy died
and the guy got found guilty so it's not
like right
it's not as celebrated it's not there's
no it's not about class or any of that
it's not like all the [ __ ]
oj was um
i my sense was that white people
liberal white people were very relieved
like i think a lot of people were
relieved just for just a like a moment
of like
okay great that worked right that
worked after a year of
talking about how [ __ ] doesn't work yeah
and most
i was not confident he was gonna i
when that like other cops were turning
on him it's
and then the guy who flew in
to get to say that he yeah and carbon
monoxide
uh gravel sidewalk somewhat sidewalk
itis
um uh the like
that one that guy looked like a [ __ ]
goofball
now apparently he's being investigated
by maryland yeah which is good
he should yeah great um and
yeah i get the feeling white people were
like i couldn't read another book about
racism
and i'm just glad that for another
few months i don't have to donate or
march
or do anything i don't have to think
about
my terminal whiteness i don't have to
think about it just like
okay i can just go back to ignoring it
more or less right
being aware of it and go ah everybody
was
morally off the hook yes cool great
yes now republicans i think at least 46
percent of it might have been 56
of them didn't uh yet 46
thought it was the wrong outcome oddly
enough all of them
said he should have been charged with
something which is very strange
in and of itself but they didn't like
the murder
the second degree yeah again that's one
of those things
like what it's like when someone breaks
up when you go i didn't like how you
went about it
how what should i have done what should
i have done you card
what do you what what's like the how
should i have broken up with you yeah
sir or miss um
the interesting thing happened the other
night this is a total side note about
sir
miss yes so i'll do jokes about men and
women right
my stock in trade and i can
see gay couples in the crowd
disappointed men two men
how do you know they're gay you can tell
um because people look like what they
are
that's how i can tell they were
interacting like not too
you know to quote bill burr she look
like a lesbian the same way you can tell
when there's a lesbian
um what how could you tell everyone's
everything nope
uh so but i could
censor disappointment and it's one of
these things where i don't know how to
it's like i don't know what to tell you
because i can't talk about you guys
meaning i can't i don't have any
experience with
gay couples so
i don't like just i guess just be
disappointed
for now there's not gonna be they were
i don't get what their disappointment
was meaning i'm going men and women
i'm describing men and women right in
just relationships as
the norm which statistically is the norm
but i can see them
all right at least i felt them be a
little disappointed like well
this doesn't apply to us what about us
yeah
and to which i my response to their fake
query my fake response to their fake
query that i'm projecting onto them is
i don't know what to tell you what part
of it
is that you
maybe some sort of inner like
and don't you start defusing me enough
but
i don't even feel defensive about it i
actually feel like i'm
i'm um it's like just a
uh better business like just a better
business period it's a crime stoppers
thing
where they don't they don't it's not i'm
talking about a thing that they're not
included in
okay but that's the same kind of defense
that
uh christian mingle took when they would
not let
people search for uh gay relationships
and their defense was
we don't know gay people so how can i i
can't i'm doing
gender jokes thank you for lumping me in
with christianity
but i'm doing gender jokes no i know i
don't know
it's about male female relationships of
which i have
voluminous experiences so much um
so don't you think though okay let's
neither of us are gay but don't you
think
that in each like uh in lesbian
relationships or
someone's something someone like there's
even jokes about it you know like
i don't want to do a joke about it and i
think like one of your jokes but
like no i was just like because she did
a joke about like where do you get your
protein that thing for vegans and it's
like
the the lesbian version of that it's
like which one to use the man
right and she just couldn't figure out a
way to do it she's not funny no she just
did whatever
i think she was just like i don't want
to talk about it right um which i get
but
we never there was no follow-up uh i
don't know why
but um but
yeah but i can't even i can't say that
i could be like you can't yeah [ __ ]
you're kind of your hands are tired you
put it together yourself
your hands are just um anyhow so white
people
are relieved about the george floyd
verdict uh enough
enough they you know white podcast those
no longer have to have black people on
for another year
enough with all the racism talk you know
you're not listening
white people don't have to listen do
they listen
neil's putting two hands on the white
person
and white people are the only people who
listen noisily
hmm
and now the question
that kept coming up in in my head as
well
it so there's the thing with
uh madeleine what's her name the
con the the congresswoman um
the black woman uh madeleine
no not malindeen black woman it's not
madeline it's uh
maxine maxine marzia um
i was like madeline uh she said
something
trump's i'm sorry biden said something
and just like that's
tampering witness stanford whatever is
there
first of all trump said a [ __ ]
shitload about cases so
let's try those as well right anyhow is
there something about
barbarians at the gate or pressure from
the outside world
that affects outcomes to which i would
say like
yeah that's kind of the way [ __ ] works
meaning if you don't find him guilty
there's going to be a riot right but
there's so many
cases where it was like no that's in the
bag
100 on camera yeah cops in the wrong
or somebody in the wrong and they get
off so
it's not something foreign to people you
know what i mean
yeah my question is they're making it a
thing now where like well black people
are
extorting uh uh they're extorting
convictions
yeah from from us and it's kind of well
aren't
weren't white people kind of doing that
where it's like
not with riots but no you move the case
oh this can't be fair and impartial
let's move it to an all-white
reflex like probably one more word about
simi valley
and i swear to god i will hit you on
camera
i don't care i'll get away with it as a
good white man um
but yeah but that's not even that of
course that but
i just mean there's so many tools they
can to roughly do the same
arguably do the same thing which is but
also just white
norms are the barbarians
at the gate do you know what i mean just
like the idea of like
of the the the the the
sort of foot hearing footsteps or like
what house is going to reverberate
i think maybe not as consciously but i
feel like
juries had that in the back their heads
of
whether they realized they're not just
enforcing
norms right and so this is a new norm
and i i get i'm not opposed to it
what are you what are we talking about
what are you not opposed to really quick
i'm not opposed to
the idea that black people are at the
gate so to speak
ready to pounce if the jury if the
verdict if they don't come to the right
verdict
so like i'm not
i don't know if it's justice exactly but
neither is what's there now so right
at least i mean this is it's recriminate
it's you know
it's just it feels like eventful in a
way but it's
i don't the the existing system is
vengeful
right and of all the parts of the system
apparently the jury system is the least
that's the one that actually does
function it's what they're allowed to
hear what evidence what charges
they can only do so much you know what i
mean yeah
but i don't know i find it funny that
we're now we're talking about
not like you bringing it up but
are juries getting influenced by the
outside i'm like that's of course a
jury's going to get influenced by the
outside world like that
is part of the point that's why they get
sequestered so this is anonymously
important
there's no such thing there's no such
thing truly impartial it's like i ha
i'm black i'm i'm right dominican i'm
white i'm rich i'm whatever
like i'm gonna have biases yeah the
the process of eliminating a jury is
crazy you know
it's like they do background checks on
unc have you ever seen
runaway jury is that a john grisham you
think it is
yeah it's so funny i don't know i was on
a plane i was playing
it's terrible they'd only played on
planes i feel like just straight to
plane
yeah um it's so funny they have a whole
like center of tracking every juror it's
like
no send someone and then a guy bumps him
and
it knows it's terrible it they put way
too much like there's not a team of
people monitoring the jury
yeah it's very funny but
we are so obsessed with juries you know
what i mean we're hyper obsessed well
jurors they're just like us
i mean i mean it is like that it's a
it's a focus group with big consequences
but we are not nearly as obsessed with
other aspects of justice system as we
are in the juries it's like they're the
least i mean a lot of lawyers get book
deals
lawyers yeah sure but there's like
systems in
you want more focus on bailiffs things
like that
i mean just you know
like i don't think people realize how
much power like judges have to allow
certain things
the whole thing is no one's impartial
you know
yeah yes there's no there's no such
thing as
uh it's the it's i wanted to
confess to my biases even though come on
everyone
already knows the guy who was saying
remember the guy who wrote in the email
and said like about exterminate all
brutes and
how it was we were basically like
talking about white eugenics
um what i'm i i'm
i'm predisposed to side with black
people
because because of
dave giving me an opportunity so i'm
never not gonna
side with black people for the most part
so just know that
damn imagine if dave was a woman oh oh
forget it i don't even know
predisposition
dream i mean keep dreaming um
so i'm pre-disabled and as a liberal
there's not
much downside to signing black people
do you know what i mean there's no like
you're not no in your position there's
no
there's not much downside very little
risk yeah um
so i'm sitting pretty good
i'm like i'm doing great uh lebron
tweeted
oh yeah what do you think picture of the
guy who killed the girl in
mc in ohio and he tweeted a picture of
him
with the words you're next uh
close-up of the guy apparently lebron's
gonna be a witness in the case
based on the shirt the nike shirt that
says witness
um so neil
um seven hundredth week in a row
really hit me strong uh
so you're next and then accountability
now
your next made it sound like we're going
to kill you right
uh even though he followed up with
accountability so
accountability right as usual people
taking [ __ ]
at what i call thin slicing and going
he said your next no he said your next
accountability um
but and then he took it down and
said that people are always trying to
you know yeah
so but the funny thing is i read that
um that where derek schopen's being
held waiting for like his
sentencing um all of the black cos
were are not they were pulled off of his
area not allowed to work
um wherever he's being held i don't know
whatever block
it is no black co's are allowed over
there only white cs
well and somebody's suing who's sewing
the cos
yeah so basically everybody are they're
getting their shifts
cut yeah they're cutting shifts
it's everybody who's not it's not only
black it's just
only white people are allowed to um
monitor and patrol and work where should
derek show me dl
hughley his whose instagram is
almost all just shooting videos
it's basically face to death it really
is rotten.com yeah
and um i was gonna write
when it said derek chauvin is on a
segregated
ward i was gonna write underneath well
i'm sure he's a segregationist
and i realized like that's probably not
worth it no it's not but um
yeah chauvin's never been happier this
is his dream
he's just like i'm alone not a black
black guy in sight um i'm finally i'm
safe
um he's he hasn't exhaled like this in
years he goes to jail
to feel good waiting to exhale um
basically
yeah so uh so that's
that and as we all know that
so you know out of the frying pan into
the fire
uh then what's the girl's name
makai uh bryant mackay bright she gets
killed in a uh
the guy shoots open shoots first
questions later of course the the
question is
what would you like a cop to do if
you're getting
stabbed yeah yeah
it's i don't that one's tough because
first of all i don't like how much the
guy looks like me he really
i'm not happy with it he's receding
hairline neal that's correct
and and no bowflex nail
no bowflex no bowfinger no bowfinger no
bowflex
uh yeah so
the problem is okay let's say so i read
exactly what happened
and it it's like convoluted but let's
just say
you're getting assaulted in your house
which is i think what was going on this
is foster care
yeah someone visited arguing over
the house cleaning it was not like worth
anybody's life
um again which first of all
anybody in first of all the fact that
cops have to manage a [ __ ] house
cleaning
is like just it's the mayor of chicago
to quote last week it's just
like what i'm in charge of [ __ ] house
cleaning disposal
well it obviously of course escalated
right but i'm just saying like that's
what the cops that's like what they're
tasked with here
it's just [ __ ] like oh [ __ ] you it's
mayor of chicago
yeah so the problem is okay let's just
say you're in
the pro what the cops saw what happened
beforehand is not that important so
let's say you're getting assaulted in
your house
and you wrestle the knife away from the
person and then you're going to sound
you get like what is their what's the
how do we get justice when you call the
cops
and you need help and they catch you in
the wrong
frame you know they catch you at the
wrong time
well yeah i that's the uh there's a
there's there's
when you are if i arrive at the scene
that's a
[ __ ] even the frame the freeze frames
of it are
chaotic no you don't know what it looks
like the
uh one of those frozen challenges thing
what was the
they're called the um wait wait it was
that race drummer song
yeah it was the uh mannequin challenge
yeah the mannequin challenge
like even the mannequin challenge don't
you don't need to look it up everybody
knows
um except for yeah wells what
um so the that's not even a good one but
the
it looked in the other frame at the top
of it
the the that guy looks like he's
stomping somebody it just looks [ __ ]
crazy
it does look crazy so if i show up at
that
cat's point of view was like if i'm
getting stabbed don't
shoot at the person who's stabbing me
because like what are the odds you don't
hit
the person getting like that's you got
to be a
really good shot they could have easily
both been dead uh-huh
um so
i don't know it's hard because there are
so many instances of
people doing this that are white that do
live
that's that's that's that's the the
uh problem and
the well the i i don't know if it's the
outlier but it's like the in an
experience in the a
b if it's white people probably not
firing shots no i mean there's so many
examples of
coming at police like not even somebody
else and yeah hey
stop no yeah wrestling him you know i
don't
or like can you you couldn't get her in
the calf
i don't know i don't know though the
problem is that i don't have enough
tactical knowledge of what they're
trained to do
to know if like he did what he was
trained to do
the training issue senator black black
female center said he did what he was
trained to do
which then goes like okay well what was
he what was he trying to do
that's the training like she was on one
of the sunday shows i don't know who it
was
yeah i i don't
know it just seemed so chaotic i
understand that
shit's chaotic you're there to solve you
have to make quick decisions but
i don't know it's also just really bad
timing and
it's just bad none of it's good it's
just one of these like
[ __ ] i don't know man it's hard to look
at that
and i understand that
hey there was a level of what do you
want me to do let her stab
the girl and then they would be like you
just let her kill her
because you i don't know but i i get
that there's enough examples
you know who would have really helped
this scene who spider-man
what would he have done gush to the
knife
should knife close-up of the knife close
up of the spider web coming in
grabs the knife pulls out we go wide
would you
uh would you invest in a kickstarter for
a gig for
black spider-man black crime unit
um what do i have in the back
with the trash oh a shredder no well i
have a paper shredder of course
but i have the uh compost the compost
bin yeah wait
i gotta spin it oh
yeah well they're all manual sweetie
this is a sweetie it's sweetie
um they're so anyway there's a
countertop um
one of those so no they smell no this
doesn't
they got it they figured it out i feel
like you know the snl skit
where adults are just um it's kind of
meant to look like porn but people are
really on zillow
that's you on kickstarter just what can
i because it's really like
it's the price is always pretty like 80
bucks
okay okay what are you all doing over
here
we haven't had a dumb purchase and what
are you all dealing i bought one of
those key fobs
for the apple the apple key fob that
is getting papa bats because you know
how to google this once you buy
something they're like well show them
some ads about it
i don't get it uh what does it do just
to find your key
yeah it's the little thing it's you can
put them on anything
i have one of those but it was not apple
well
and i got it years ago so uh yeah one of
those with the
oh the air tag so
i don't know why that looks like such a
yummy
um so
so yeah so so i that's one of those
things where
this is kind of above our figure what
are you gonna do
what are you gonna i i i don't know what
obviously
i don't know what to do and then when
you go what if they were white i
wouldn't have gotten shot
so there's the problem how we handle
that i have
no idea i mean i it's just deep it's
seven layered it's a seven layer dip of
of uh racism and psycho
and psychology and slavery
and fear and this [ __ ] we talk about
endlessly for 102 weeks in a row
they love it we've given it a go every
week guys 102 weeks in a row we've tried
to solve the problem come back next week
and watch us try to solve these things
of racism now moving on
i don't know if this qualifies as racism
but
johnson and johnson jj uh
they they're back
they took a week off they took a
two-week hiatus
and they are back now they most
americans don't want it
yeah i bet they don't well i said that
they should um
they should give out the johnson johnson
vaccine
at the outlet mall because it's
like it's lightly it's irregular
they have some irregular vaccines
slightly bruised i know but
but also people think like people that
you know the odds of getting covered
were like
you know one in 50 000 or something or i
don't know what the getting or
doing it okay 32 million so about 10
of america got it right so one in ten
one in ten not one
so and one in ten and people were like
nah
i don't think it's going to happen i'm
not catching one in ten i like my odds
and then they go there's a one in a
million chance you'll get
right blood clot uh i don't like that i
don't like those numbers
okay no i someone i'm on a group text
and this person did not care about covid
yeah didn't care about
any of the risks and then started
posting everything about johnson
and i just wrote stop why are you
fear-mongering yeah when you didn't care
he was like i'm not feeling margarita
i'm like
everyone on this text that is afraid it
has something to say against a vaccine
does drugs you do
cocaine and among other things i'd love
to be brought into your circle
it was uh i'm not gonna doubt what kind
of text it is but
it's a lit i think the word you're
looking for it's a lit ass
it's lit ass thread it's just you do
cocaine
chill you're good if you weren't worried
about if you do drugs and you weren't
worried about
the vac the catching coven
yeah it's just people have no
consistency at all
with what they like oh no one in a
million nailed it
that's me um
i'm one in ten but i am one in a million
i know that's unique
yeah it's all the people that weren't
worried about that
you one and ten it's like yeah it's the
same thing of like
but the odds of them making in show
businesses are one in a billion and
they're like no i just
have a feeling um
so best of luck johnson and johnson
people aren't going to like you and they
should
uh they're just going to go to the poor
countries
yeah let's be honest let's just keep it
real you know
although i have a really good well this
is a nut
so all the poor countries are mad
they're mad because
the rich countries are getting it first
so this is my
as i think i've said on here maybe not
um
if you're if you believe in justice and
you believe in
uh privilege and you believe in sen i
hope you sent your vaccine to india
something tells me it didn't right and
i'm not talking about johnson johnson
anyone could send it johnson johnson
i'm talking about one of them sweet
modernists and advisors
and people you ain't given what about
your privilege what about your vax
privilege right your vax prix meals come
for everyone
no but it's just like i watching these
people like you should give up
yes and pretty girls are going to give
up drinks to
the to the plain looking girls at the
bars it's a world of constant justice
and
except when you have to do it i say that
as a white man
so i've got i've got a vested interest
in not
giving up my privilege but no one does
is my point no one does and the vaccine
uh inequality is that is going to last
longer than
the pandemic but what i would say to
those people is like so what did you
wealthy countries got the vaccine yeah
wealthy people get the new iphone when
it comes it's like that's just how
wealth works
and it shouldn't apply to
health i agree but
ah what did you think america and
england were going to
say like sorry citizens right by the way
that would have actually helped with
facts
uh desire in america uh if they gave it
away to poor countries it would look
yeah one thing so it's such
bad writing i know it's so easy i know
um
so so exactly what would have happened
so so they did you think we
what would we say like no we're not
gonna give it to our citizens
we're gonna give it to old people in
bangladesh it's
just like not the way that not the way
the earth has
i don't know ever worked but kind of
ever worked um
also did you see how we're gonna hit a
point where we have more vaccines than
people who want it
yeah on on thursday i think
basically happened already yeah so
we're hoarding everyone's hoarding yeah
well it'll be good for negotiating it'll
be like
you know yeah which is so moral it's
just
the moral failure of the world
yeah but we get all the i mean i don't
[ __ ] know
i don't know it's not your problem no i
know governments yeah it's like
but i'm i'm saying you can't do anything
about that
like we can't do anything but except i'm
not even talking about citizens i'm
talking
even if i'm in the government i don't
know how to solve it
i don't know how to tell my citizens
sorry
even though you pay taxes
we're we're going to be fair about some
[ __ ] for some reason
because we're not fair about anything no
no no i don't who makes
no if you expected this vaccine rollout
to be fair worldwide that's
you're a sucker you suck ass marcus
buster
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you got your head out your
ass
uh but i do think if we've reached
once we reach a point where okay you
don't want it
because i'm gonna give it to africa yeah
well well wait no where where are they
let me see them
[Music]
yeah all right well i'll take the first
shot um
and honestly some people that i know
that
are being very ignorant this year are
like
did you take moderna like i love that's
the new one
the new that's the new what airline did
you fly
what oh yeah what how was the flight you
[ __ ] come on man
who gives a [ __ ] you know the difference
between pfizer and moderna right and
astrazeneca
do you know that do you [ __ ] you know
johnson johnson because his blood clots
everyone knows that right stop asking me
because you don't know what the
you don't have a follow-up of them
yeah people that's the question what
it's just small talk one-on-one right
yeah yeah it is but
yeah it's sad uh
so yeah um
what is [ __ ] fest cheerfest is when
ohio state has a chit fest every year
and uh it's just a street
so they have a celebration on a street
named like
chittel anyways [ __ ] fuzz is just
it's just party riots they all and like
cars flipped over heavy do you see the
party riots in the house tonight
go ahead um i found it interesting that
one no one talks about it it happens
every year
um they damn it they have the police
have a task force
to figure out how what to do they
surrounded this whole
two three thousand person party that
we're destroying property
no arrests made no
i don't know we just we treat it so
differently and i'm not gonna
and that's not to say they have never
had any punishment i went back
but this has been going on at ohio state
since the 80s
every year it's just party riots
and granted it's in more interesting to
look at to me i mean it's just funny
it's like just kids
there's no one makes me less comfortable
than that
age boy
about more than two like uh
i was confident like confident but also
like giveaways that they're not common
don't know what to do with their hands
and like
just like looking dude always looking to
the other guy see how they're
just really uh students that they're
so those were all student cars they
destroyed everyone's like do something
about it but there were
no arrests made they were helicopters
the whole time they were surrounded the
whole time
no arrests may i just find it funny that
we don't talk about
this is a yearly riot mind you it's they
have different fests for
that guy seems not white so he's going
to jail oh yeah one of the
people of interest is asian i was like
[ __ ] not this way [ __ ] around find
out number 18.
number 18. um
stop asian hate week is about to end i
bet
yeah yeah so anyways it just it's funny
that we
treat yeah it's just one of these a b
things it's like yeah
why black people couldn't do it it's the
it's beyond
it's so beyond hacky at this point it's
just like yeah
that's a [ __ ] that's where it is it
is
i'm not saying we everybody should ride
and loot i'm just saying no no i'm
saying you're saying white people get
away with
wild [ __ ] wild that why
as long as it's in the some it's like in
the good old boy
yeah like that's just ohio's
you know boys being boys yeah so it's
it's
interesting um now the oscars it was big
for
um it was it was big for um
for well it was a big it was a champs it
was big for the champs podcast
trayvon won yay trayvon one
uh um uh amir was the dj
quest love amir questlove thompson
mayor tops um
james poyser did the music for
for trayvon's movie that's on netflix
um who else dan even though it's not the
champion yes friend of the friend of the
pod
of the pod yeah um dan who
bianca calls him dan and i i took me
five seconds to realize who the [ __ ] she
was talking about dance
yes well will likes to do this it's a
speed scroll
yeah um so
so it was who else somebody else uh the
lucas brothers who were champions yes
they
they did not win promising young woman
one what did they do they the
lucas brothers wrote the dan's movie
they wrote
they they yeah they wrote the first
draft and then it was rewritten and they
got story credit
cool yeah i think it was their idea to
do a movie about it
um so that's very cool and who else
um that was you know pretty pretty
pretty the most
of the most winners i've ever known
um i thought it was funny that did you
watch it i didn't watch it
no i saw trayvon's speech that's all i
just saw the clip
i can't watch the award shows this oh
they're i mean
they're nauseating they're not their
whole thing's nauseating
i didn't watch i just watched trayvon's
speech because it was there was a link
to it and i was like i'll watch it
kaluya i think gotta laugh on his dan
as you as as he's known um
dk um no neil
d uh so
so uh so yeah so good for them i hope
you
um he made a joke about his mom having
sex
oh um lovely so um
the funny thing is that it was
and union station downtown l.a and
did everyone end by saying i gotta catch
a train
i'm hoping that'd be so funny why'd you
write that i don't know why because i
just
assumed so everyone would do that joke i
gotta get on the 823.
if you'll excuse me anyhow uh
the funny thing is is as i i you know i
am a houseless warrior apparently uh-huh
so they displaced so many
helpless people to do uh the oscars
there
so many they couldn't go back to i mean
you know again i
that's one of those things where they're
not supposed to be there either that's
the problem it's like displaced from
a situation where yeah they're not it's
not like they're supposed to like oh
good
it's not a homeless station that has
trains no
but i mean that's what it was it's not
like in the actual
thing it's just even around it and
you know it just was it was just uh in i
always feel like these award shows tried
to
be very you know honorable and
moral this year there was so much
comfort so many hands over chests
uh meanwhile there's homeless people
that yeah
it's just funny it's just a funny joke
here's a tip for everybody
just don't pretend you're righteous
just don't pretend you're righteous
because your gut there's no
end to there's too many layers of
hypocrisy
it's like i'm righteous where do you
live america
how in america was found oh it said we
slaughtered
millions between six and a hundred
million native americans that there's
they're so in they they don't know how
many they thought
too many to count countless native
americans yeah uh
so yeah so
the hypocrisy doesn't end never ends
so just stop acting like you're
approaching
things from like i'm this year i'm
giving for this awards ceremony
to millionaires we're going to
everyone's a millionaire except maybe
trayvon might not be
maybe though no maybe no you don't get
money for it
he uh yeah i don't [ __ ] know look at
that i'm kidding
i'll ask him i'll just say him i'll see
him at the bank if i see him at the
right bank i'll know
so i don't so congrats to all the
winners i i
feel like kaluya had a good spirit about
like he just
kind of had like a yeah what um yeah
yeah he got it
got an award like got an award you know
like doesn't don't make him all
nottingham yeah um so
you know good but i'm happy it's not
going to hurt any of them
it hurts the women generally that's that
yeah that's the good news
the women if you're old enough it's
mcdormand
more the same yeah anthony hopkins more
the same
um the average voter's 63.
so that's pretty funny so like right
there like what are you guys
campaigning for what is it with the
grammys
i don't know probably something similar
something similar yeah
uh it's yeah it's again [ __ ] messy uh
so um best best
be best be best to all the winners
congrats i hope it meant to those of you
that it meant something to
i hope that that meaning grows and to
the people who had it in perspective
like kaluya
uh and i think the lucas brothers i
think they all i don't [ __ ] know
[ __ ] them neil's got to catch a train i
got an a247
um oh oh
armenia just went genocide yeah
armenia went genocide they finally
joe biden finally acknowledged that
uh that the turks slaughtered the
armenians
and i've been hearing about this a long
time 106th anniversary
um yeah and it's the first time an
american president has referred to it as
a genocide
and for his troubles the kardashians one
of the kardashians thanked him
so let that be a lesson to the rest of
world leaders
if you want to get thanked by kardashian
let's call it a call it a genocide i
don't know very much about this
been hearing about a long time 106 years
106 years i've been here about hearing
about it
he went to the premier league the
genocide
um and
just between 800 and 1.2 oh
armenian men and no not even men
worse than worse than men women
are meaning women children elderly and
infirmed
were sent on death marches yeah in the
syrian desert
uh i see the word rape say the word
massacre
uh another wave two hundred thousand
we're looking we're getting somewhere
between
around i'm going to put that number on
1.5
under reported yes uh yeah it's just
it's a long saying thing turkey doesn't
want to say they
um committed genocide and then no one
goes against turkey so i don't i'm
like good it's you know what made me
realize
even on a small level human to human
we need acknowledgement of things
you could be we can be in a relationship
and you can beat my ass every day
but if i say you hit me you're abusing
me like no
i didn't no that's not a i don't know
why it [ __ ] with someone that may be
why
but it may be why when a guy does that
like
baby no i [ __ ] up get sick and it's
like
he acknowledged yeah that's probably why
it works it does because people
want to be acknowledged that's why
sometimes you wonder
like it almost seems crazy and
insignificant why black people like just
admit yeah it's racist yeah when there's
all the evidence in the world well it's
what trevor always says the difference
between south africa and america is
is they didn't pretend they weren't
racist in south africa they just didn't
they were like yeah no you're not you're
not as good as us
right so we've got just different laws
and so
you know pipes got different
infrastructure so
he said it was better he said it was
straight up better i think
mentally it's that you're not
going you don't quite you're not being
gaslit i hated the
you know i hate the word gasoline but
sometimes there sometimes you're being
asleep
um and they're not being so you're not
crazy
you're not crazy and i think everybody
wants that
even in europe i it felt like the racism
was
a little more overt but
in a completely different i don't know
it's just digested differently i'm not
saying it's better or worse but
i was like black skinned person you know
it was just
it was like they're cheating and they
don't pretend they're not
yeah i know i'm thinking about south
africa it's like no we're cheating
we're cheating so and you go oh they're
cheating
then you can all live your life like but
yes um
it's it's a buddy of mine was asking
he's like i'm i'm i have a woman coming
in for the weekend
how do i make her not fall in love
right and i said
you under 48 hours is good
friday late afternoon to sunday early
afternoon you'll keep it under 48.
and and when you talk you need to have
like a
statement of intentions up front okay
what's that look like
i this is what i told him
be honest and put the word feelings
in every third sentence i'm
i my i feel like i don't want to
jeopardize
your feelings so i need to be mindful of
that
and i want to approach this with your
feelings
being sort of on a pedestal i mean you
don't say on a pedestal but like
you know and you just go you feelings
you feelings you
you you and you're basically
acknowledging and therefore
you don't know they can't get mad
because you brought up
feelings and feelings you can't argue
with someone's feelings
right that's the that's the beauty of
feeling weird conundrum where it's like
you can't argue with it if i have a
feeling i can't
people abuse that [ __ ] that's how i feel
no
well morons and
and manipulators the two m's
um they they they will manipulate it but
if you just mention the feelings and i'm
my worry is your feelings will be hurt
if blank blame it
and people go i was hurt
it's that con that that uh hostage
negotiator
who said the most important thing
after people be yelling and i want da da
da da da da da da da da da da da da and
we go
if i hear you correctly what you're
saying is
and just read them back and he said a
high percentage of time they would stop
the they would let the hostages go just
because they were
heard yeah um so armenia
you got heard now stop it i don't know
what you're i don't know what you were
doing
i don't even know it does hurt our white
eugenics argument though because it i
don't know if
i don't think turkey turks are white or
armenians are white
wait what's going on here what do you
mean that they're the
the white people has most of the
slaughters of the last hundred years
no for sure but i think the problem is
by the way a million if a white people
slaughtered a million people you
wouldn't even hear about it
that's like for white people those are
garbage numbers those are garbage
numbers for white people
a million people [ __ ] out of here uh no
i think the
what he was saying the emailer was
saying that
it's not only white people there's
plenty of people doing it to each other
but our
point was and i'm like honestly i don't
know if he could make that
argument as he emailed back and
was sort of like all right and then kind
of reiterated it
to the point where i didn't even put it
on the list because no it's too long but
think about it like if he watched
eliminate all the birds
openly and really under try to open it's
a lot of information
it's really hard to walk away with that
much information these people have
dedicated their lives
showing systemically how uh white
supremacy and all that stuff has
oppressed a lot of people
and through genocide through a lot of
ways
it's really hard to walk away from that
be like ridiculous arguments
you know well i i think we narrowed the
argument to
recency our bias was recent
right which is a common bias but i think
other than this
small blemish on our argument that's how
i see the armenian james that is the
blemish
i'm not about to stand by i live in this
no it is a blemish on me
and our argument he made you look bad
joe biden by acknowledging this um
armenia you've been heard
and turkey uh i have a funny
tur it's a funny dave chappelle story so
you're welcome
ring the bell we should have a some kind
of dave story
bell bell if you can think of it send it
in
um he was once in
turkey at a four seasons or something
and he in the bar and he overheard an
american congressman
talking to a bunch of locals and the
american congressmen said
we love the turkeys
so that that happened
um caitlyn jenner's running for
is gonna run against gavin gavin newsom
which is um here's all i want to say
about
caitlyn jenner people doesn't get enough
credit
people don't acknowledge this enough bad
personality
very boring basic
simplistic not interesting person not
interesting in the slightest in the news
a lot in my life
as bruce and then as caitlyn
and it's i think it's it's
it's uh pretty clear
that that caitlyn's not interesting
because
she had a reality show that didn't do
well and it's like
what do you mean the kardashian no he
she had a show after that
i am caitlin i believe um and
yeah i'm kate yes uh yes i am kate
uh even the font and the photo is boring
yeah i don't it also doesn't look like
what it is
says that's how they can tell you that
you have cancer
they just hand you that listen that font
i am kate
um so yeah in two seasons
you're from the kardashians
you were the most popular one of the
most popular athletes
of the 70s and then you gotta you
changed
gender and you still couldn't get
ratings
like [ __ ] hang it up hang
it up yeah she just i think and by
it i mean your male genitals
oh white nails which she did
i just don't it like the ego
on certain people what makes you think
you're qualified
i don't know a lot of i feel like
there's a lot of
on state level in government i think
some unqualified people can come you
know
like i don't know what's the
qualifications
to make a great mayor or a great
governor but
i don't know if she has someone who is
affiliated with government in some form
and then was like i think i could do
this
yeah i could be i like if you're a
lawyer you're a public
you're whatever you're you're you're a
lawyer who deals with the municipality
yeah it's like yeah like something
affiliated
not olympic athlete
announcer kris jenner's husband
transgender right that's none of that
goes yep governor i think next stop
governor
i would have bought it more in 1977
right when after the olympics um
so also the thing is so the
the what is it it's like a gubernatorial
i don't know i don't know the words but
um
so they recalled him because of
all the conservatives in america in
california didn't like his
policies of like shutting california not
letting him
now that things are opening they have
the they have the likes
they got the signatures yeah they got
the signatures a long time ago i signed
it twice
i was reading that there's first of all
now that we're opening
most people don't care mm-hmm because
that's how
dedicated people are to their like moral
compass in politics
it's like oh things are good for me it's
just like i want turn the heat on
just like you weren't gonna kill the
landlord you just were cold
right exactly yeah so now it's opening
and it's gonna be opening more
and people care a lot less and a lot of
people run
in these kind of things so it's not
gonna be
gavin newsom versus caitlyn jenner it's
going to be governors versus
15 weirdos yeah hopefully
they're as interesting as kaelin
and by interesting i mean not at all
interesting hey will you scroll up well
i saw something
yeah and then go back back a page you
you had something up
that i found interesting oh her net
worth did you see what kaitlyn's net
worth
it was on the one of the wiki pages
a hundred million dollars what pretty
good
pretty good um what how the [ __ ] should
you have so much money
that's so much money uh i well first of
all who knows if it's true
thank god she got she got paid every
episode of the kardashians
that's not where she made the money but
uh just weird
i'm sure that's wrong oh 2014 estimate
right i'm sure that's wrong but not like
things have happened well since then
you know she probably spent 80 on the on
the gender
stuff uh just on the hormones oh i had
an interesting
thing so born william bruce jenner
1949. yeah he's 71. now that
he's a woman now now that she's a woman
will she get that two-year life
expectancy bump
that women get you got to think about it
something like you i'm look i'll cover
all the angles
bianca um also it said that lgbt
activists are not excited about her they
never know
she was against gay rights like
and and transgender rights like you have
to have a base which is
an idiot she's not smart and it sounds
misogynistic now
yeah right now you're 90 years ago now
you got the pronouns right five years
ago
there was a man who looked a lot like
her
and i didn't think he was smart okay so
consistency
uh neil's putting his hands up he
clapped and put his eyes
like don't take it elsewhere
moving on i don't want to hear it did
you hear uh
the twitter outrage about elon musk
hosting snl
uh yeah i do wonder what's going on here
i didn't they
it's a thing they've george steinbrenner
hosted steve forbes hosted
it's just a thing that that uh
it's like part of it's a type of person
that lorne will have on
and i the fact that people are upset
about it
uh embarrassing and there's no outrage
when the baja men
came on snl was it is that true
yeah of course i mean i feel like i just
feel like snl is like they take
whoever's
they'd say whoever's in the news yes
that's correct so but people
saying that it's i don't even know
so they're mad that he's conservative
i don't know we talked about this a
couple weeks ago he says dumb [ __ ]
he's done more for climate change than
anyone alive
so i kind of don't care
the good he's done for climate change
you you almost can't on literally the
goodies done for climate change
you can't undo with tweets yeah
literally there's not
a tweet he could make that's
that's worse than the good he's done i
don't think he's pr
personality-wise he's super interesting
he's a [ __ ] goofball he's a dork
who's trying to
be cool that's what he's doing and those
those people make me very they just yeah
it's just
it's just what kids call cringe
trend cell crunch so
uh yes he if once you know what he is
yes
is he does he try to be cool and say
like cool
[ __ ] and name his kid a symbol and all
and i'm
with grimes and it he's he is a
scientific genius yeah
so i don't i all this other [ __ ] is like
you're not gonna believe this people not
having their priorities straight
then getting like so
what you're mad that they're letting him
host a sketch comedy show
i for one bianca am flying in
and gonna write for it no you're not
that's correct i am not oh yeah it's
like
you are i hope they go though i feel
like okay
every line i would write is uh uh elon
and then in parentheses botches line and
then the
and then the line um because he's just
going to botch it
he's going to watch everything i don't
know i think it's better
kyle is elon musk it's it's outstanding
uh but i also i hope don't look it up
for some reason
you looked up 75 things won't look
up comedy video that will you hit play
we can listen to it will
all right this is joe biden oh and elon
everything i love elon with craig
caitlyn jenner is so funny elon
joy beer wish you a congratulations on
your face space
launcher a big deal man not not facebook
it's
face x space sex launch
uh cool sorry is this joey b
former vice principal under barack
toboggans come on man president erect
oh cool sorry i'm distracted with
kirk over 19. kids will do that to you
i think you think of my son ax f-12
great
so you get the idea you get the idea he
does the one with caitlyn jenner and
elon musk is so funny it's so good but
yeah so
uh i don't know yeah i just don't care
i don't care it's he [ __ ] is he
created the greatest electric car
by a factor of a thousand so shut the
[ __ ] up
how about that everybody no that's how i
feel about it right now
yeah did he call a guy a pedo because he
was trying to be
cool and funny he's a [ __ ] dork
all of his mistakes are unforced errors
trying to be a dork
is he anti-union yes
i don't care because the thing that he's
anti-union about
is the only company helping the
environment
so if you got to be anti-union about
something
be about electric cars anti-union
oil you can't host snl
electric cars putting his foot down it's
the
address is 30 rockefeller center
the entrance on 49th and 50th street
depending on which part of the city
you're coming from
one uh 50th street goes east 49th goes
uh west so that depends fifth avenue
goes south and
should i go on anyhow uh
the la the uh bianca oh well shock g
died
the one who put this stat on that i know
um shock g died and have you met him
i don't think i have come on think he
wait he's known as humpty hump
piano man rackadelic m.c blowfish
gregory racker
i see mike i didn't know all this uh
you didn't really need to i don't think
that jit got a dolphin nose
that's funny uh he produced i get around
one of the my favorite
hip hop songs ever certainly my favorite
tupac song
uh what about when your homies call no
i'm not yeah i have
you know i have a complicated
relationship with tupac um
and but i get around as a [ __ ] killer
and i'll say this for shock g
seem like a nice guy seems so he seemed
like a very fun guy
he seemed fun even i could see that
someone who's not fun and doesn't is
funny
but it's not fun um don't invite me to a
party did you ever do the humpty
dance uh i was too this is one of those
things where
everyone was in high school and i was
not you were in high school in grade
school and i was
an adult i didn't do dance styles
okay so
that's correct um so
so uh you know my thought was
with dmx and and shock g and
uh black rob dying in the same week i
had the thought
so so what it looks like the way this is
going to happen is just everyone dies
and then i die
is that how life goes that's my
understanding am i
am i misunderstanding this in some way
everyone slowly dies
around me and then eventually it's you
it's me it's my turn that is
kind of cruel when you think about that
life totally aggressive rat race
no just you st i don't think like that
right now but at a certain
age you start seeing people your age
your peers
people that yeah just falling where it's
not i mean
louis does joke about it where it's like
it's not
uh it's he's at the age where if he dies
it's not going to be a
tragedy or it's like oh he lives
i don't know it's hard and you go okay
are you less uh are you less obsessed
with
mortality after old higher risk
um yeah well now i don't
i mean now i know
i don't even believe i know that i'm an
eternal spirit that will
is just in this body for um
a finite fixed amount of time and same
with chuck j he's in the he's flying
around yeah
uh but yeah that i but i
i still don't i still prefer not to
burn the hand life is a bird in the hand
it's like ah
i believe that i'm that it's you know
eternal spirits
um but yeah birth man
do you have a preference of how you want
to go
on top i want to go out on top of who
the haters
um no how do i want to die i i guess
just
aya no i'm not gonna die no i'm just
saying would that be
uh what's your choice yeah that yeah
cause that's where you're gonna be
anyway like that's you're going there so
sleep i don't see dying you sleep scary
to me how come
because this is sleep this is just
it's it's own thing why do i have to die
and i already sometimes dreams feel like
you're gonna die
i don't want that to come true
yeah but you don't know what happens
i want to die i want to freeze to death
i'm sorry what i would have did that
because when you freeze to death there
is a
your brain starts releasing all of
the dmt the dmt the serotonin
it you are in a euphoric the most
happy state you'll ever be because your
body knows you're dying it's like
for someone who doesn't love drugs
that's a very surprising thing to say
i know and then you feel warm you don't
feel cold
which is very important to me you're
very it's very important to every woman
and apparently neil yeah um you're very
happy
you don't feel it you just are in the
all the euphoric positivity your brain
ha like holds in it in different places
it just floods you with it
it feels pretty good if you have to go
out
real hearing yours i realize how i want
to die how haha i want to get my head
chopped off
let's move on get the gucci no
just like industrial a hack just a plate
so i'm going to blade
chops my head clean off and then it
spurts spurts birds collapse
it spurts for like three beats well so
is your head still not realizing
because that's what i do um
cat's been pretty bad with pointing out
the amount of times that i cut people
off
and by people her because we have to
talk all the time
um so that's
uh and then the la homeless got a good
ruling
what happened they all need to be
offered housing
oh yes i saw that um
this is one of those things where the
difference between homeless and unhoused
is it's what they call a distinction
without a difference like
um just okay what do you okay
do you need a place to stay or not it's
like is that the priority
uh overseeing sweeping lawsuit about
homelessness
ordered the city and county to find
shelter for all unhoused residents
it's only skid row though so it's your
people
down there you're down there vigilante
camera yeah yeah vigilante selfie it is
slammed officials inability to restrain
the unprecedented growth of homelessness
that has seen encampment spread into
near nearly ever
somebody made the observation that they
could take a lot of them are in hotels
the project turnkey or room key yeah so
if you
some of these hotels aren't gonna
probably didn't survive the pandemic but
they
these buildings still exist yeah there's
a lot of just
empty rooms where people can be yeah
and i'm all for it
the problem is that so
like at echo park there was a huge um
homeless encampment and
they cleared it with like riot you know
what's funny
so i read about it 200 homeless people
all of them they all got reassigned
homes
no i know that's what was about yeah but
the problem was the
protesters who none of the homeless
people were protesting
no people no no so the difference is
that so there were
there was only like less than 100
people who didn't uh take the housing
voucher and it's because
the housing vouchers are really strict
so you can't
bring in um you can't bring certain
like a lot of their possessions they
can't bring with them obviously
but it puts them in a predicament
because that's all their [ __ ]
and they have to they just have to agree
to a lot of things and so those people
opted out so i did try to tell people
when we
when it was being discussed like the
city did offer them housing
it's not that they didn't it's that they
not everybody could
we're in a position to take that housing
because of the rules so then those
people stayed
well you say in a position it's
preference
it's preference but i don't know they're
i don't i'm not going to go out of my
way to
speak on their possessions i don't know
what they have to think
what i'm saying well first of all
there's a lot of homes people near me
right now and i gotta say
you know who i would like to see
intervene with some of these homeless
people
maria condo because these [ __ ]
have a lot of [ __ ]
they have a lot of [ __ ] and they need to
decide if it inspires joy or not
and then get rid of it because there's a
it's like use this a lot of [ __ ]
within a year in have you used this tin
a [ __ ] bicycle rim
have you used this no that's my get your
hands off my bicycle
no we're going to decide today
all right i don't need it it seems like
a lot of that that
again i'm being funny no you're being
funny i just i i don't
i don't use that wording to be overly
cautious
i just don't [ __ ] know i don't know
if they have medical medicaid i don't
know
it's a bigger issue which is i don't
want to live under
someone else's rules i just don't
meaning that's what most of you aka this
country
it's i was you know how you always think
uh
where handicapped people will be
defensive like no
i got it like i got the door i got the
it's kind of a similar thing of like i
don't want to have to deal with you
picking my chair up and like i don't
want like i don't want with me i don't
want
anyone to pick me up right as an adult
i don't want you to pick anyone but
that's what happens is
when you have money and you're a
different class you want all your
freedoms but when someone is
seen as like a nuisance or a problem
we're just like police
government take their option away
but i don't i feel like part of it's
legal [ __ ] meaning
if i from the government
get nobody wants people
in their neighborhood living on the
sidewalks no of course right it's a
nuisance
it's a health risk it's a bunch of [ __ ]
it's a eyesore it's a bunch of [ __ ]
um so as much as it's like rich people
going like police it's
nobody wants it so they so then so then
you go okay so
the municipality has to go to them and
say all right we're going to give you a
new place to stay
there's all sorts of legal ramifications
on the municipality of course
when you've kind of forced someone into
a housing situation
that so i'm sure their list of
[ __ ] you can't do is i
i'm gonna give them the benefit of the
doubt and say it's largely to avoid
lawsuits
i think the reason why it's such a
problem especially in la
is because it's a really hard problem to
solve
so i i don't fully understand it i uh
my only solution is find a city that
improve their homeless situation and
analyze what they did i don't know
that's like all i can think of
finding new work by the way didn't fire
it this newark
pd didn't fire it no newark also oh yeah
did you fire a shot
last year no it's like they're both
doing yeah
but know what that's the weird thing i'm
like why aren't we talking about
the experimental pilot programs that
work and
it's hard it's hard to manage people
people are hard to manage it's also hard
to
governments and there's like turf wars
in chicago
mate it's again glory life we're all
light foot now
um everybody like foot everybody do the
light bulb
that's a dance um
now so oh i also had a thought about
racism
come on now which is what makes me good
at writing about it is that i
bring a rational mind to an irrational
thing okay but i think the mistake i
make with racism is trying to approach
it
like it's rational right and it's like
this is not rational
so you're trying to bring the [ __ ]
logic to an
emotion fight it's like it's a [ __ ]
cr it's all crazy
yeah it's crazy so there's i sometimes i
give
i approach it like well you're being a
lot but
no one's logical or when you do make a
little headway with logic
it there's just this yeah there's some
they will jump it
and go well we didn't like that outcome
he should have been charged with
something what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
murder seems a little rough for
murdering that guy well what did he do
yeah um so
and uh congratulations dirtbags
in new york they made prostitution
less illegal in new york city they're
not
again i thought it was they like
legalized it it's just one of these
things where
it's decriminalized it's they've they
will no longer prosecute
prostitution and unlicensed massage
unlicensed first of all i think i've
been
guilty of giving a few unlicensed
massage in my day so i'm happy
i'm happy that i gave gave unless a
little five against one
a little a little joe biden the old joe
biden special they offer that at a lot
of the
massage parlors now it's just a joe
biden where you sit in the chair
and out of nowhere a guy comes up and
just rubs you
um i learned a lot uh
so i it's i thought it the headline made
me believe that
it was going to be dirtbag central but
it's
it's it's still they're just not
prosecuting
certain [ __ ] a lot of it had to do with
trans
rights where they were it was like
walking while trans
was what they called the the law so
i don't it seems better but i don't
know exactly how because if you scroll
even a little
keep going uh
they would i don't i don't understand
it's one of these things where it's a
lot
they're still prosecuting pimping pimps
and john's
but not which is like i i don't know i
don't understand it
i think it's because the
women in the situation get prosecuted
way yeah like a higher rate yeah so
but i read about this in
a lot of advocacy advocacy groups say
that decriminalization is
actually better than legalization
because legalization
does drive up the uh black market so to
say
like right so decriminalization more
black customers
that's why you want to go ahead uh so
i think from what everything i read it's
good
better yeah not good yeah yes it's
better
i don't it seems like we need to figure
we have some more
work to do in figuring it out like i
i still you know mike there are guys
that
cannot have sex with women
and we kind of punish them meaning that
the guys that no woman wants to have sex
with
right but in this situation we're
punishing the woman yeah
yeah no i'm saying what i mean make it
all make everything legal except the job
except the pimp part right but the
problem is that
people get
i don't know from what i understand it's
not always just a bunch of dudes that
can't get laid
you know of course not i but but i'm
my point is
if you make the pimping
illegal um
and i'm sure the pimps will the guy sent
an
idea about the pimps um but the
if it's two consenting adults i don't
give a [ __ ]
no no no gives a [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] it's not like
well this will lead it doesn't a lot of
slopes just are slopes
they're not slippery you can just
they're just a slope that you walk down
it's just a gradient yeah it's just a
grade it's nothing whoa
it's not you just go walk down the slope
it's fine
when they made you know when they have
zoning laws
it wasn't like and now we can't build
houses no
do you just have laws some sometimes the
slope is the slope is the
um so rest in power queens
the the the sex workers in queens
um now
i watched sasquatch on hulu it was very
interesting because
you think it's basically about this guy
who was in humboldt
in the 90s and a tweeker ran
in to this house and was like dude
[ __ ] sasquatch just killed these farm
workers at
some weed farm down the street and he
never could get that
um story out of his head and he's like a
pretty good journalist from what i read
like he
had he went undercover and like the
neo-nazis
he also did a piece where he was
sexually assaulted and he
in his adult life started stalking his
the guy who sexually assaulted him and
like
did a whole piece for maybe new york
times i'm not sure um
but yeah so he was like a very
interesting
respectable journalist and he had this
story
that he never could get out of his head
and so he went he set out to figure out
is there a sasquatch because that story
happened and then
it's him deep diving into the
seedy ass world of
uh mendocino humboldt's weed farming
like out in the woods i didn't realize
until i watched i watched a documentary
called murder mountain
like a few years ago or maybe last year
and that's when i realized how
[ __ ] up it is in the like um
in those hills where they they grow a
lot of pot in california and so
he went back and had to track down hey
like track down the guy
tracked on the farm try to track it on
the tweakers track down everything to
see about sasquatch what
and you think it's going to be about
sasquatch yeah i still do
it is it goes it it starts exploring
like could this be
okay people say they've seen them up
there they do that famous video
whatever and it goes to
so many it's i can't tell you what
happened
but it's interesting it's interesting it
is
it's it's only three episodes so it's
good
done um they he finds the guy he says
he's like does a story about
blank blank blank ring a bell a guy's
like
yeah that's always real and then
and also everyone is
a criminal in this like everyone's like
no do not use my name
do not put me on like everyone is it's
so seedy i did not realize what was
going on in the mountains
yeah of northern california i did not
realize the amount of just
human corruption if humans are there
it's gonna be corrupt that's it
like that's it that's why
american government when it works works
well because it is
constant looking checking each other
for corruption we can't not be corrupt
yeah that's it we can't we're incapable
of it
like it takes you have to be kind of a
crazy person to not be corrupt
literally it's i mean that's why when
people are like zen buddhists
or something like come on well that
there's that
come on there i believe in that again
anyone advertising their righteousness
is automatically um
but there's because because of the thing
that
me and ken are working on it's just a
lot of looking at
certain woke people and and my
argument for most of these against
really
anyone but they're holding up their i
said if most of these people were
confronted with the
the option of help yourself help the
movement
they're all helping themselves which is
human nature
so and the only people who are are uh
will help the movement are people that
are
[ __ ] a little crazy wait wait
they're bipolar they're like a
chemically
hold on what movements are we talking
about here uh most movements
even when it's you know civil rights i
feel like you see civil rights
like i don't think malcolm x or martin
luther king or
any of those people but what i mean is
so it's those types of people that are
truly righteous that are like navalny
now is on a hunger strike
right because he's a [ __ ] a little
crazy
so you need someone who's a little crazy
to
[Music]
actually be for this [ __ ] well yeah to
actually not be corrupt you have to be a
little
insane it's it the the level of
corruption just and i get it it's weed
it's the even
they're saying how legalizing it it's
kind of similar with
the sex workers the now you know there's
like a legalized
industry of weed it's made the black
market even bigger
well yeah the thing they didn't account
for with wheat it's tax tax if you if
one party is taxing it the other party's
not right
i'm going to the other party of course
so and it's just all those people
it's like the old west it's like don't
come up here
yeah um don't because no one wants to
get
robin they go back when got a shaky
handheld of him running off people's
property
there's a lot
um they deep dive into the hippies that
kind of founded those places
and the the dea kind of just seizing
and then that's changed the hippie
vibe of like everyone welcome stop no
guns
it's like okay so i just grew these
crops for a year
so my kids can eat and you just raise
them yeah you just took them in an hour
yeah and then they started having ar-15s
and automatic weapons and maximum you
know the confederate flag shows up for
some reason
for some reason and then the hip some of
the hippies are like that's not what
this was about man
so now up there you don't go sniffing
you don't just
go for a casual stroll like hey how's it
going neighbor
no what do you want you'll get shot up
there
even now it's so take that mixed with
lore mixed with racism makes with
classism it's just it's
more interesting than the title i
believe that okay
all right i'll have a look at david hot
house that's what his name
david hot house guess not not a fake
not a fake name um
let's do some emails huh guys
i like how the email song is probably 15
seconds
and we both take the up the opportunity
to check our phones
it's 15 seconds this is my opportunity
sometimes you do it
during well that's only when it's very
know that i only do it if it's
very important um
oh okay so what do we what do we got we
got an atta boy bird song
detroit house that was that was i
believe chicago
is it chicago yeah i think that they
were
chicago that kind of
i believe you uh that was from richie
acevedo
which sounds like chicago um
and i believe he sampled rick ross at
the end which is going to cost everybody
a lot of money
no samples guys it's cute but
they get us taken down go ahead
[Music]
that's from eric
schlicht um
if you really want to sounds racist
um
feels like that last name doesn't
like jews neil that's all i'm saying
anyhow go ahead this is his other song
eric
what are white people doing
here's the thing that it used to be what
are what are these white people doing
and then it became what are white people
doing
yeah now it's a little more if i don't
want to
i mean it's been wrong since the
beginning it's
and by the way we don't call the whole
podcast should just be called what these
white people do
it really is i mean really ultimately at
the end of the day um
so those are all winners
see on the show thanks to richie acevedo
and
eric eric schlitz
seven jewish people died when i said is
when i said that name
um anyhow here's a video question
you've got mail hey neil bianca my name
is nicole i'm from north carolina
and here's my cat orbison in the
background question
uh to you both since doing ayahuasca
or however you say it um have you
noticed
a difference in your relationship with
animals has your relationship with keith
maybe gotten a little deeper
or weirder or uh binks has
have you had a knee encounter for the
animals that have been weird since then
i don't know if you have a dog or cat i
don't think you do
anyway thank you guys for the show
accent um
cute cute keith and i
he sleeps closer to me than he's ever
slept in seven years
really yeah he's up there all the time
well that's because he's afraid of the
setup
um but he used to be down more he's up
when you're up
yeah it's it's i he was
i had to move two nights ago because he
was breathing in my face which has never
happened before
that's so and anyone who knows keith
knows he
don't got good breath no he does not um
so so
he sleeps there he's he's never slept
closer to me
and it's [ __ ] very cute [ __ ] very
cute
i have a new idea for when i repeat
something
uh just means that that story went into
syndication
it's such a good story i syndicated it
and i bring it up
i sell it to hulu and they air it
whenever they want
that is so thank i repeat stories too
like you already tell me them
yeah it's for emphasis great story it's
for emphasizing
it's seinfeld some of my stories are
seinfeld it's so good and we'll repeat
it it's syndicated
um anyhow another video this is a from
an electric car this is a pov
this is a pov of so you'd live life as a
[ __ ]
in an electric car i'm kidding go ahead
casablanca rolling down the road here in
a semi-autonomous vehicle yep
i got an aftermarket unit that works
with a lot of cars
i got 1275 miles on the car i just got
it
and uh bought it to drive cross country
and
is this a craigslist video what's
happening neil i know you got a tesla
would like to know your opinion on
self-driving do you trust it
do you put your tesla in autonomous mode
when you're on the freeway
got you guys up on the laptop here oh
you do not correct he has so much
technology just listen to the podcast
and uh
neil i think he's a cop this looks like
a cop car
um i there was another
um crash tesla crash
no one was in the driver's seat it's
just dumb
people this is what they do they get in
the driver's seat they put on autonomous
mode they
click the seat belt they climb out of
the seat with the seat belt still
clicked
and some people put like uh you clamp on
the
something on the steering wheel because
that's the thing you have to jiggle the
steering wheel every 40 seconds
right and then it used to be in i talked
about this 65 seconds
and then there was one crash and they
made it 50. then every crash they
it's like they're ruining it basically
so you're just like
you just gotta jiggle look i'm texting
don't make me jiggle
um i don't get why you need to not be in
the driver's seat
what's the desire well you want to talk
about
truly ghost riding the whip come on
you're
these guys made it they became ghosts
during oh no ghost ride in the whip um
they're infinite spirits they're with
black rob and
and uh by the way the dmx [ __ ]
funeral procession cool with the monster
truck
you know trump saw that was like wait
wait wait do monster tricks
um totally i do i know dmx
that's right he's now trump is like biff
loman
and that's his death of a salmon he's
like deaths of a salmon
of a salesman it sounded like death of a
salmon
yeah i'll come for you you barely speak
uh
rough right yeah i mean amazing like
[ __ ] hilarious
this is hilarious to me it's so on
it's so on brand it's like it it's
beyond bright show the coffin the coffin
is
i didn't even see the coffin is wild no
just show a photo of the coffin
it's there look at it bianca you
what it looks like no it's it's
spectacular looking
it has like rough right it's just a it
looks like a 90s
album it has a lot of funny prints does
it have the parent
parental advisory sticker on it that'd
be fun
um i heard they kept it behind the
counter because it's a black coffin
anyone remember that anyone know what
i'm talking about they would keep black
they would keep hip-hop records behind
the counter at record stores
oh yeah yeah that's right i thought you
meant like black hair care products
no they which they do hip-hop and they
used to keep half-baked back there
because it was a black it's like oh okay
um you guys think it's no we know why
he's predisposed
yeah well of course every the
everything's personal
um uh yeah they would keep uh hip-hop
behind the counter so he had to like
could i have wow yeah really you may
have white people
you try to think rationally don't bother
don't bother
uh anyhow we were talking about your car
tesla my car do i believe in
self-driving i do but you just do it you
just jiggle it and it's good for
it's your 30-second break but what i
understand is that
the obviously the car can't see so if
it's a if there's no traffic
it's just going to go through your stop
signs and stuff
you can only do it on the freeway you
can't do it in
yeah you can it doesn't recognize stop
signs it doesn't it's just
freeway driving speed and lane that's
all it can do
so which it's very clear about these
guys are just
idiots does it do you have to be going a
certain miles per hour like is it only
you can start it at in traffic
and just set the you know it's just good
for traffic when you don't want to do
this
it's good for traffic and it's good for
going
80 on the 10
and you just want to look at your phone
for a second
does it make your cell phone habit worse
has it made yourself uh i don't know
it's already so bad
who knows have you used your cookie jar
in a while i haven't
what happened was okay your honor
okay you all know me no i when i was
doing the kevin commercial
i had to turn it on because i had to
deal with emails all day and then i
haven't
put the clamps back on yet even though
it's been a week neil bought
a cookie jar everyone else
he bought a cookie jar with a timer on
it and he puts his phone in there
and it worked what did you do
i started a podcast you [ __ ]
you're on it okay um is that
i did [ __ ] i know the turning the phone
off i wrote i wrote a ton of [ __ ] like
it's
i just there's an app called freedom
that just i just haven't
i haven't turned it back on but i have
to turn it back on
wait wait uh it just blocks everything
you can't i can get text
that's it but i can't check i can't go
on any internet i can't
and it blocks my computer my phone at
the same time wow really
yeah so i just have to read or work or
write something
pretty good stuff nice job freedom
anything else
goodbye i love it what a what a
multimedia podcast we have
you've got mail hey so you both
mentioned you don't know the police
hiring process
okay so as quick as i can you apply
online
you'll then be scheduled to do a written
and a physical test
in general for smaller departments these
tests are a lot harder
you'll then have to interview in front
of a panel
with police officers and civilian
employees
you'll then have to fill out a
background packet which is
pretty much all the information in your
life ranges from all the places you've
ever lived to all the bad shape you've
ever done
based off of that background packet you
will be asked
in questions in a polygraph exam
then you go to a background interview
with a background investigator who will
ask you
questions based off of that polygraph if
you even pass
it then he'll start his investigation
which will be three to six months long
during that time you'll go and take
another physical with the doctor to make
sure that you're
in shape and you can do the actual job
and then sometimes at the end you'll
have another interview with the chief of
police or with the board of supervisors
or whatever
but in general becoming a cop is really
[ __ ] hard especially if you're an
older person that has a lot of life
experience and a lot of [ __ ]
that you've done it's really hard
it's hard but it's not uh
in terms of training hard it just feels
like
have you done have you [ __ ] up and or
did you get
caught [ __ ] up did you get caught
it's almost just like a hard background
it's like a really high bar for
background checks but it's not
that sounds like a pain in the ass it's
a bigger pain in the ass than i imagined
no fully but i'm i feel like we were
talking about you know iq um
do how much training do you get for the
job
not how hard is it to qualify for and
that's interesting i didn't know that
but
i didn't hear anything about tactical
training
well i don't i guess they do
it's just not very long um like six
months
no i hear that but i've heard four
months
so uh what is the cop iq thing
people sent in the a few
uh a few
police you know it's funny 600 he wrote
664 hours to train for a cop
to be a therapist it's like 3 thousand
oh it's
on to be a yoga instructor it's a
thousand it's like
what so next time a yoga instructor puts
you in a choke hold know that that
chokehold is safe
that is a safe choke hold uh
a bunch of people send an email as well
but not quora
like they think will people send in
emails about it not
audio emails no i'm saying just click on
the email because the email has links in
it
okay audio emails
a new thing
okay so this is the they're people
sent in emails about
um police iq levels
okay so it's this is from 2000 but i
think the
law stands a man whose bid to become a
police officer was
rejected after he scored too high on an
intelligence test and
lost his appeal against the city oh my
god that's weird
he appealed because he's a he's got a
high iq
um all right this kind of puts an
official face and discrimination in
america what
did they can you give me some background
scored 33 points the equivalent of an iq
of 125.
only candidates who score he scored 33
on the cop exam which is like 125 iq
and only candidates who score between 20
and 27
can be cops because the theory is that
those who scored too high could get
bored with police work
are you serious that's so [ __ ] funny
that's so
funny that i didn't realize the answer
would be so
that's fun i mean it's like when dave
was like they all should go to college
i'm like
you don't go you don't become a cop once
you
once you get an edge like you need to be
it's funny that they assume that smart
people will get bored
because i don't see how you get bored
when your life is on the line
but technically maybe
uh it's probably it's not you know
they're not in
hand-to-hand combat every day
if they're good cops there just finding
the real ones are the weirdest thing is
my neighbors
[ __ ] weird it's but they do have
bonuses
for police who have a bachelor's degree
i mean they do but that doesn't that's
not an iq test
what they're saying i know that they
don't want to train people because
they're going to get
because if they have a high iq then
they'll leave the police
no i know what they're saying i'll leave
the four i that sounds like [ __ ]
that sounds like i feel like you can
find examples where there's people with
high iqs that
they have no problem with them becoming
police
i i don't know how to find yeah but also
what it sounds like
they just don't want smart people doing
it
if that's true because that can't be an
official reason
i mean that the reason they have the law
what's the law is because that they
don't want
turn they don't want to train them and
then they
they learn the job and then leave right
but that's again sounds like [ __ ]
yeah there's a good documentary in this
really what's going on
no no i'm not i'm saying like someone
could make
a good documentary about police
just the po like even that [ __ ] that
people were saying last week about how
it was like
slave it was all slave patrols that
became
um i'm sure there's thousands of
documentarians
listening they probably don't
encounter this that often
the high iq thing the high q and like no
i wanna
let me do it no well it's also like
if you're there's a way to tank the test
okay so you could go undercover
21 jumps a smart no it's 20 it's okay
it's fresh out of water but it's a smart
person as a cop
he's out of him he's used to being
around the movie i just thought of two
hits
in the last two minutes uh we by the way
we had some
um from last week's really from
the clip of saying soccer players are
hot
what was the problem what with the
reason harrison barnes
nba uh
he's a good nba player um
was felt dissed harrison
harrison barnes who who plays for
sacramento
and maybe the leading scorer harrison
very happy
very handsome married and oh what is he
cuter than um i'm protecting his wife
married uh oh he got corona so he's
he's got [ __ ] going on he's doing [ __ ]
he got corona this season
um and he can let me see his stats this
season
he's got nice shoulders harrison he was
cuter in college i believe
everyone's cuter in college his average
this season he's
six eight huh uh
i think his season that's for regular
season just go
go to all of them uh
his stats this season
he's averaged um
16 points i thought it was a little
higher okay the that did
they're a young team um so
pretty cool uh their young team and he
was cuter in college because he was
skinnier
i didn't know he was a listener
i didn't either bianca you never know
who's out there
listening and i don't know how much of a
listener is
hey pretty similar body no he was i like
i mean you like his body better well i
mean he's
very cute here but he's also cute and
yeah he's cute
those arms i'm like his arms are a
little more thicker now
so anyhow and uh is that what your arms
look like
right after i get off the flex yet
yeah they do that's cute the north
carolina was
dribbling yeah right oh yeah
yeah it's better okay anyhow we like to
appraise male bodies on this show
and uh wale felt that wale said he was
gonna take up soccer
cute well he does fine he does all right
in the lady business
he does when he does travel to cities
people do [ __ ] him so unlike you
bum ass [ __ ] um
i also think women
women will happily like women's
expectations
for having sex with a rapper basketball
player
are so much lower than they would be for
me
wait your expectations are lower their
expectations for me
are like you better you better do this
and this
and this and whereas them it's like you
remember my name
they're excited they have no
expectations um
anyhow goodbye um here's do we have any
more audios
one more wow give them one more you've
got
mail what up neely billy long time to
wednesday
lst ner writing to ask that's nice how
will has made such an incredible
turnaround
these past few months i think everyone
can agree that
will would regularly f up to the point
where we all thought it was a
bit but neil's genuine frustration came
through enough that thank you
i was even saying to myself damn bro you
really about to lose your job
but lately his music and effect drops
have been fire
it can't just be him getting a new desk
so what gives
spirit padres showing him management
touch pay raise benefits
what is it so uh what neil b thinking
that's a great question and we're gonna
add will's gonna answer in a second
um but
oh by the way he's regressed this
episode it's one step forward
he's turned all the way around he's
worse than ever he's
this is probably his worst ever episode
if he hit record on this it would be
that's a shock uh will do you want to
talk about your heart
i thought you'd never ask
[Applause]
[Music]
hello feelers this is will
over the course of the next 14 hours
i'll be diving deep into my art
deeper and deeper dives from bad googler
to adequate producer
chapter one my birth the year was 1991.
my pregnant mother arrived at the
hospital at the same time neil arrived
at the premiere of eddie murphy's
boomerang
well no i realized i don't have to take
this [ __ ]
and it helped i relaxed there you go he
relaxed
everybody but but it was we did
we did have a heart-to-heart before you
relax um while you're relaxing
can you put the timer so we can see the
hour i just oh
yeah you can't see it thank you this is
my worst episode yeah
all right so we're all in the same place
yeah okay all right great um
he relaxed and he relaxed i did have a
com
i did have a heart-to-heart with him
father-son and
[Music]
uh but he got better also trying
i think people kneel i wanna i wanna
hijack
let me hijack this right quick
um let me cut myself off for once
um try don't be afraid to try everybody
that's all i'm saying goodbye
you've got me um hi neil and bianca no
time for cute introductions although i
will say i'm
of the elite thursday watchers club um
in episode 100
you discuss how sex work being legalized
makes it safer
because it makes pimps obsolete i was
surprised how you overlooked the golden
sketch idea of a temp service
for recently out of work pimps feel free
to paco delicious me
this just needs to get to the people
the he's that's a very good sketch
uh i would also
either a different sketch or part of
this sketch
it would be job they would go to job
retraining
like a job they do a camden new jersey
yeah they all get
re they all go to like a class like
i have a question um and then
whatever they all do different it's a
bunch of like a cut
i have a question a cut to a like 10
pimps in a classroom right
you're uh it's you're getting a big
laugh the chappelle's show the last tape
i know
um that would be so yeah good
eddie murphy had a [ __ ] hilarious
pimp idea sketch
that i will not say because someone will
pocket delicious it okay
but um and then dave had a [ __ ]
hilarious beat on it i think i mentioned
on the champs once but you'll have to go
back to
the tapes um yes
i would do drop retraining and then
placing them
in jobs um including one that just came
to my head
nanny a pimp
dog walker for dog walker of course
keith
of course
um yeah like i ain't picking [ __ ] up you
pick
what you ain't i ain't picking your [ __ ]
up the [ __ ] i look like and they'd have
rhymes about it
because that's pimp's speak only and
right i was like
um starting to feel a little yeah um
oh i'm sorry i should have done a white
pimp there are white people i know
there's like two of them
no no no white bone and they're they're
literally
about how they're not black their names
are like
i'm not black my pimp name is i'm not
black steve
they're literally based around the fact
that they're not black
yes even when you think you caught me in
racism you're caught
wiggling out you dis pray you diss
yourself goodbye you've got i find it
weird that bianca can't understand why
millions of white people would care
about the historical plight of black
americans and thus watch roots
i watched it faithfully in the 70s when
it aired uh as a young white girl i was
riveted and heartbroken by
a cruelty i had never before understood
and knew too little about
and i didn't have woke parents or grew
up in diversity i cared anyway plenty of
white people from everywhere
despise cruelty and inequality racial
injustice even when they are very young
and inexperienced and less aware of
their relative privilege that still
persists hopefully
the ones who wanted to see roots and
empathize grew to understand that
i would assume so sorry just thought it
was
weird that she didn't understand roots
uh
okay so what i i can totally understand
millions of white people watching roots
my issue
the reason what's confusing to me is one
bruce is
the most watched thing on tv i think
after the last episode of mash at the
time yeah
and then some and then the you know
super bowls are right up there with it
so what's confusing to me no
there's a weird genre of entertainment
in this country where
it's the whole point of the film or the
movie or the show is like black people
being abused by white people
by evil white people everyone watch
everyone's seen a time to kill
no one's rooting for the white people
okay so everyone can get behind
everyone can get behind black suffering
what i don't get is a lot of those
people are still alive and
and it's even today black people have to
con it's the same conversations
it's the same conversations from the 50s
60s 70s
80s 90s and today the conversation
hasn't changed much
well what black people are trying to say
and you would think that something would
have happened
where it's like within the month the
month window after they watched it
yeah or it just it that that you know
that
resonated with them and they took that
uh
with them into the world but it seems
like black people are still having to
convince
a lot of a particular part of white
america that
no no it's really still very bad in
terms of
racism and judgment that black people
get and i just don't there's like a
disconnect
so i'm not surprised that they watched
i'm surprised that it
seems like didn't do much i think what
i'm hearing
if i hear you correctly what you're
saying is
representation doesn't matter let's move
on okay
goodbye you've got me a wall in dolph
banks don't know what that means
and free willy don't know what that
means uh
t-h-r-s-d-watcher
here uh should i feel bad about
continuing
to accept oh this he just gets right
into it
should i feel bad about continuing to
accept unemployment wages
i have been working in the restaurant
industry for over 15 years i could
return to work now but i get paid too
well not to
part of me feels like an [ __ ] for
taking advantage of the flawed system
that was set up for unemployment
compensation
but i also enjoy it well in that case um
it has allowed me to help family through
troubling times during covert
restrictions and [ __ ]
i won't bother you with the details but
i assure you i've been useful however
i've also been able to save money while
not working
which entity slash person is the biggest
[ __ ] in this situation
i'm a big fan of all three of you we
care about you will
um i don't know what entity could be an
[ __ ] in this situation besides him
yeah i mean
okay so like ppp loans were basically
um forgiven
if you hired back people and if you
didn't the rate is
so low yeah there's no real incentive
there's no
but that's not what he's talking about
no no i'm just setting that up so
to me i'm like well there's plenty of
people who got
loans and i don't know if they always
needed them or they were like i'm not
bringing back these people i just need
this for my own personal
self selfish not selfish reasons that
sounds pejorative but just
well i just need this for myself sorry
right now tough times so i think
right now i think you have like a year i
feel like
if uh in 2022
you're still doing it all right so
you're calling amnesty
yeah you're going like no harm no foul
too many it's a it's a wild time it's a
wild time and there's too many um
variations on everyone's situation
what you don't like it uh i don't
i mean you know when you think about the
amount
i just wish they'd give [ __ ] less
money to buy bomb i just wish there was
less military oh okay
budget and more to people
it's funny though we people there are a
lot of people saying
you know giving too much money
we shouldn't give so much money like
even with the 600 i mean there are
people who
thought that was insane where are we
where is this all coming from
but uh i am
the military budget is insane secret
right
or not it's it's public they don't i
don't think they
tell it's not i don't know they're not
like potatoes the
bombs where and they'd say where they
keep them uh
it's
defense budget 714 billion
and you know
it's a [ __ ] ton of money that's so
much money
yeah it went up and like for what we're
not
yeah it does yeah it should all be cyber
and that's not working
so but yeah it's only 715 billion
um anyhow
so i i you know you gotta you got you
got once it opens up
stop it um okay
um what's up neil and bianca i caught
myself leaving the bar on tuesday
because y'all uploaded eight
slash nine and it was a great decision
yay congrats neil for joining cam'ron
in killing calvin aka kermit when you
snuck to cuba to kill franklin
pops snowfall season finale
and paid in full references you're a
great company i have no idea what he
literally no idea let me let me get that
clear
swing in a miss correct uh my question
for
you all is what's the wow this thing all
caps y'all
put up with in a relationship because
the sex was otherworldly and what would
you do
do now for it
i bet you got a good one um
i'm like there's so many um
the problem is this gets upset every
single time it's so great
get upset i just you get like you you
truly
flinch no we have a thing it's funny
okay you have
you for some reason make it weird well
right back at you okay uh so
i think
i'm like i don't want to say that one i
don't want to say that one um
the problem is the sex
[Music]
play all my thoughts yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh the someone told me they sent in it
me sneezing song we need a song for that
oh
i never heard that i've never heard that
one when they submitted but you've never
sneezed again
we didn't hear i don't remember that
okay well well being a bad boy guy gets
one letter and he's starting to tell us
about the podcast
uh i do you go because i'm like uh i
there was just a girl that was so
nuts and she
tracked my car put a low jack on you
yeah it turned out two different guys
had restraining orders against her
oh my how long until she showed crazy
pretty immediately how before or after
the sex
i mean before i mean
look bianca i
i don't know but it was she was crazy
what did she what was the biggest oh
no no just every just kind of every just
showing up places i was
started taking walks on my street for
some reason
uh like just while we were dating it was
like yo
you gotta chill the [ __ ] out this is
there was no reason to do it
no she kind of lived near me but like
there's other hills how did you um and
coming to where we get coffee just like
just crazy how did you end it
uh i basically
she banged on my door at one point it
was really crazy and the funny thing is
almost worth it she was so hot it was
almost worth it she get in bed yeah i
mean
yeah okay i mean good it wasn't even
good like she
died [ __ ] no no but just it was just
an it was just a
real nice connection we'll say that
um i god i don't
know i'm different i don't if you're not
mentally great i become less attracted
to you
you must be pretty wet right now
because who's greater
but yeah so i and then i'm not into the
sex if you're
weird if you're acting crazy so i have
had relationships where
it just digresses because i'm like
this is now nurse patient you're
not able to deal with your own emotions
so all the crazies i have i
the sex became very bad or like
non-existent
yeah this girl was like jealous it was
crazy it was
crazy but that's the difference between
guys and girls because
ah maybe it's i bet their girls listen
and have been with jealous guys that
they
still like [ __ ] or took it as a sign
of something right
eventually though it's i i i'm different
people have makeup sex i don't like that
if i'm not in a if we're not good i'm
not horny
bumper sticker [ __ ] that's bumper
sticker [ __ ] straight up
okay if we're not good i'm not horny
um look i've worked in bumper stickers
17 years and then let me tell you
something that's a hit bumper sticker
bumper stickers kind of fell off anyhow
was it was there at one point
it was the main form of community it was
the internet of the seventies
it's true it was bumper stickers you
gotta
you gotta put that something something
up with anything something
first time writer love your show two
unrelated questions so no hard feelings
if you only get to one
uh first this is about music rights this
wasn't interesting
no this was just about and then there
was another one about
um struggling with the choice of using
been a stride
for hair loss and wondering if you've
ever had any experience with
any as a middle aged man with a full
head of hair the potential side effects
are scary and include erectile
dysfunction
uh which you've discussed somewhat
publicly it's a side effect of
medications you've taken
it's true uh what did i say dick dick
issues
um uh obviously i know you're not a
doctor but wondering your take on it
side quest for bianca how important is
full head of hair on a guy
for context i'm 34 tall white and skinny
and have historically had a full head of
blonde hair that's been an asset to my
looks
wondering how that will affect my
chances on the market as a single guy um
go you i don't know if you're balding
that's like if it looks like a zombie
mask a halloween zombie mask
not good you don't like a shaved head no
i don't mind if it's
bicked or shaved or short but
if you're if you're not getting the
message
some people just zombie mask they just
leave it patchy
oh like fire marsha bell [ __ ] like no
i'm gonna i have hair like right now
that's so good
[Laughter]
uh also some guys unfortunately have egg
heads
or very big temples so i don't know i
just i'd better just to go with
it because fighting i mean
shavings never been more welcome uh
amongst like society yeah
wait what do you mean for shaving heads
yeah it's never been more just accepted
like just
squeaky for black eyes and white guys
um the
thing that came up thinking about this
was
the side of i mean that what's funny is
that guy's biggest worry about anything
is erectile dysfunction
like [ __ ] anything that's when you
come too
quick or you just when you can't get a
boner oh uh
you know one of the i started doing this
when i was probably
20. i read in
premiere magazine magazines were papers
that they would put out
once a month and anthony hopkins who
played
or not anthony perkins i always get them
confused
uh who played norman bates in psycho
said that he used to pull his hair
like just kind of grip it as like a
way to deal with hair loss
and he it like it was preventative so
i've been doing it
since i was 20. wait what do you mean
you just literally just like yank
pull your own hair a little bit just
like
get a handful of it and just squeeze
right what's that supposed to do it's
nothing but for some reason i think it
works
so i still do it because i don't i'm
didn't go bald well traumatizing parts
of your body makes them
well yeah i told you about the the
there's in
i think it's in korea they they
titty-slop
to uh to grow their boobs it's a small
world eye [ __ ] pinch
so as we learned a few weeks ago um
um yeah so i don't know try doing that
neil's favorite advice try it [ __ ] it
worked for me
and that's the only thing i did also
there's not a ton of baldness in my
family
um there's the there's a shampoo called
uh it has a bad name like narvolax or
mural
i don't know
something like that anyways it keeps
whatever you have yeah so if you're
starting to go bald just maintain
i think yeah i mean it's that's it's a
thing that guys
it's terrifying it's more terrifying
guys if you
if you look good bald right but you
don't know it's like it doesn't you
don't go oh i look good bald
go ahead hair it's just a thing that
happens to you
they don't know when or why hats don't
help
you see a guy in a hat you just go oh
he's bald
if i see an adult in a hat i just got a
small person
if a celebrity is wearing a hat more
than twice anywhere
like like the lucas brothers wore hats
last night she's bald
straight up like that's what happens i
mean when you see a guy in a hat and
and if that is the case without the hat
it's shocking
yeah which is sad i hate i hate that
sucks of course well that's the thing is
there's like a
big thing for guys that i think women
have no sympathy for
yeah like just know like i don't give a
[ __ ] you know my vagina and just like
this is terrifying that my hair
is falling out and there's nothing i can
do about it but
people will still [ __ ] you whereas all
the agents
the kind of money i have yeah
show them the net worth will put them on
i'm kidding
um yeah like you can they'll still [ __ ]
you but they don't they're not as happy
a woman and age
you want to talk about hip-hop
expectations of a woman
hip-hop what do you say musician
basketball player
comedian bald guy in terms of like the
[ __ ] you
then owe them fine but
now i think it's a low bar for guys who
[ __ ] women i don't think you have to be
a supermodel to
get with a guy but once you've aged and
you've had a child
and you just never got it tight again
if you didn't already [ __ ] that person
before
you're not as much of an desirable
no you don't even want to yeah but i'm
sympathetic to that i feel
i that truly must be i mean the good the
only good news for women is you're
probably less interested in sex
just just generally speaking women are
less interested in sex than men
i know women will argue with me about
this but but that's been my experience
okay um you're just saying we don't feel
as bad but
there seems to be zero empathy for
balding guys
also you want this a side note if you
want to laugh really hard
look at any tv clip from the 70s
and at least one guy will have a comb
over
it was you never see it anymore because
of all the medication [ __ ]
almost any clip yeah 70s video footage
there will be
there will be some guy with a comb over
uh it's all women there's the
and there's one oh yeah there you go
upper left thank you
upper left was so good yeah um anyhow
so um so do your best sir try it see
what happens
oh and then of course yank it
yank it goodbye this was an interesting
one
you've got mail as a white chef in an
indian restaurant i would get
[ __ ] for cultural appropriation even
though we use traditional ingredients
recipes and cooking methods
is there a line that you can cross with
food when you start to look like one of
those old white dudes wearing a dashiki
uh well this is the thing if you don't
he's a chef in an indian restaurant
it's just who owns it well also a lot of
restaurants the cooks
are latin at least in california yeah
that hasn't i haven't noticed that you
don't go back there
it's like a barrio oh i see your point
um uh
yeah this is the thing of like okay what
if it's like an
a place that just doesn't like let's say
it's wyoming
there's just not a lot of indians around
and you
you love i neil brandon i love indian
food so good
i [ __ ] love dipping the thing and the
naan and the thing into pop-up
um and the curry and the different
what if i want to open a restaurant in
wyoming and i'm
white no one in wyoming will give a [ __ ]
so you're good
no of course not but is it morally wrong
no
but this guy also it's not his
restaurant so right but if a white
person owns it
is that a problem
i don't know because
do you want to go to a because the
problem is also
i've gone to white most restaurants are
white owned
just statistically and they do all sorts
of asian fusion and they go to
like lots of culinary backgrounds so
whatever
the problem is when they [ __ ] it up
i think if you own indian restaurant
it's great
great but there's whitewashing there's
like pf changs there's the
i think everyone's worried you turn it
into a
pf jinx i think the problem is
just don't post about it on instagram oh
yeah meaning
21 world but what i'm saying is the
problem with a lot of the
cultural appropriation [ __ ] isn't that
you didn't do it right
it's that you're the wrong race a little
you're the
wrong race to do it um so
i don't know what the solution it used
to the old our old answer was
just don't profit from it
in an egregious way now i don't know
what i would say
because there are i can't think of them
off the top of my head but there are a
lot of examples of
someone taking a cultural dish calling
it something else
totally yeah like re-labeling it onion
what do they call it flat bread it's
like no it's pita bread
it's flat bread no it's pee well
so that feels a little uh okay
yeah i i don't [ __ ] know though but
it's also this person put in
overhead to buy a restaurant
yeah i know i know i that's the it but
our answer has
our policies change you know what it is
they will know if they [ __ ] up because
no one were either
or someone no i don't think that's the
gauge
i don't because it could be like we used
all the proper ingredients
if i don't like curry i don't give a
[ __ ] if you use the greatest girl in the
world like
or i'm averse to trying new [ __ ]
republicans are reverse to trying new
[ __ ]
like statistically they just study it
it's truly that's goodbye
you've got me hey bianca neil
um question for the spirit padre
uh wondering if the law of diminishing
returns applies to ayahuasca
since neil does it frequently and beyond
it's not one and done i'm just wondering
if the first time is the most intense
becomes less so over time or is it
still feel like a life-altering
experience every time bianca's done it
once
so uh the diminishing returns thing
you can't speak to we are grooming
bianca to do it again there's no other
word for it
um and um
and i i do not find diminishing returns
but then will told us about there's a
thing called you hit the woo
yeah and you get less and less it just
plateaus
and you get less and less from it is
that what the study said
no it's like it was a different
it was a it's a it's complicated it's
not that simple
no um it's like indian white people
owning indian restaurants
it's very complicated um
the i don't find diminishing returns at
all
the cool thing is the
window the halo lasts longer like
because i've done it
over i don't know how many times but i
mean i know how many times but
but i don't like i'm no longer telling
people because people are like
that seems like yeah
i haven't done it in three weeks and
the it i still have it
i feel like you're good for a while if
you wanted to be
yeah but it's not like two weeks ago i
was very in it
it's just it gets
i think if you've done it enough it
never like leaves you leaves you
i don't think it ever leaves you leaves
you um so
oh you believe you do it once it never
leaves you
yeah i still have the same benefits they
feel
part of me yeah just it just but i feel
the same way where's
like my brain just the neuropathy of how
to like
deal with things and how to think and
how not to deal with things and how not
to
think i don't know just stuck so
that's good yeah pretty good stuff
ayahuasca keep it up
root in power queen
she's a lady she is a lady she's a lady
by the way
my luther vandross clip
is so funny instagram did very a very
nice business
and what song did i sing you sang um
here and now
[Music]
here and now and i tagged james poiser
academy award winner maybe
did he he then did you put see the
comment he wrote under it
no he said oh that's funny
yeah bring it up well looking at the
comments
oh james wrote yo remember maybe 15
years ago i was working on a beat in
your crib when i sampled a luther joint
and you said quote who listened to lucer
vandross
and walked off and i erased it because i
was crashing at your crib and i was
scared you'd kick me out
anyways also his stories about you sound
like your stories about dave
just these random like and then you walk
off
just yell something and walk on uh
not the ones i tell on the podcast um
the uh
the the but that's also i didn't tell
him no
i mean you guys just like it's almost
just a scene out of a
show and then you like hit the punch
line oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because he could have
just said black people
and taking care of it right there no
white people do no i know but mostly how
long have you known this
guy james yeah
17 how did you meet him 19 years uh
i met me and dave the roots were doing a
session
in electric lady land in
probably 99 or 2000
it's the first time i met amir and he
asked me what happened to half baked
because he'd read the script
he's like what happened i don't [ __ ]
know man
the cute thing was this is how long ago
this was also
radiohead had just released an album
i think it was their first album since
okay computers i think it was hail to
the thief i don't remember
but like four or five different routes
gave us money to buy the cd because we
were going to the store
like all the roots were like hey i want
that album this is just how [ __ ] dumb
albums used to be
yeah someone had to go give you money
and you had because we were going to the
sam goody on sixth avenue and it wasn't
the same good he had camera what it was
but
and james was there and they were maybe
doing d'angelo or eric about that
um there are no common maybe i don't
remember
okay um but and we've been close friends
he's a he james boyz is a
brilliant musician and a
great doesn't curse really
does not curse she plays
in church every sunday doesn't curse oh
like a a gem of a guy like a truly
special guy um but
don't play a luther sample in my house
or you will get
booted apparently um goodbye
oh this is an interesting question all
right i'm a 42 year old dinosaur from
boston who doesn't know [ __ ] about
social media or have any desire to be an
entertainer
been listening to comedy podcasts for
the past few years i'm surprised
so many comedians refer to themselves as
the artist and often
cite having to write new material after
public performance
isn't that just having a job i make and
paint custom things motorcycle auto
paint sign
furniture fab fabrication when one job
ends i start another one from design
concepts to finished products
this could be considered an art form i'm
aware that art is subjective and
oftentimes
total [ __ ] is being labeled an
entertainer or comedian viewed as
less successful uh there's a former
fighter with a podcast who's borderline
who's a borderline [ __ ] he called his
comedy art and it made me laugh
so maybe i'm wrong i'm tempted to
advertise myself as an artist and see if
that draws different clientele i have a
feeling
it would get [ __ ] quick um
do you say artist um
not really what context do they say
artists i guess
i mean i could technically i don't think
it's wrong i just don't hear
the only reason this guy doesn't call
himself an artist is because he lives in
boston and he would get
he would get hate crimed they would just
he would get gay bashed
for being an artist for calling himself
an artist even if he's
heterosexual um and so
i don't this just goes to people don't
like comedians
saying anything uh
like that thing where i'm like we're
funnier than everyone
people don't like that picasso says i'm
a better artist than everybody
you go oh yeah that's true but because
everyone's a little funny
you don't want to you they don't like it
when you say like
no i this we're better at this they
don't like it they don't play baseball
so they're happy to say someone's bit
so it's just a matter of they don't like
it when you
say something's
it's the same thing of like that makes
me uncomfortable
so there's a fly here apparently and
bianca's
um having a tough time with it um
it's attacking me as races
i trained them up um so people just
don't like it when comedians are
have anything [ __ ] what they would
consider cocky
but anyone else you'd just go yeah
you're yeah lebron you're better at
basketball than
almost everybody but if if rock says
he's better at comedy than almost
everybody there's like a bit of
right [ __ ] out of here and if i say it
i'm getting beat up you're getting beat
up um
so yeah they just don't like it i think
it's because comedy is
so it's hard to be
the like it's hard to be the lebron of
comedy because
like you say not all of us can be lebron
the way you relate to com the way
we think you're funny and dave's funny
and even the greatest ones
you're still relating to me in a way
that i can understand we're still
we're still speaking the same language
yeah so because of that it's really hard
for you guys to
label yourselves like it doesn't seem
transcendent
right it's not like a song where you're
like
whoa i no one thinks they're a
songwriter a little bit
no no one thinks like i think of
melodies
but i will say i've seen people like
around
around you not as much around dave
around a lot of comedians
they start cracking jokes i'm like
you should come in my dm sometime oh i'm
sure it ha but you
you don't give off as an approachable
vibe not fun
i'm not saying not funny you're not as
approachable yeah
you're you're kind of you're you know
there's some
animals that you don't know they're
poisonous and there's some that are
neon are you i think you're headed to a
place where you're
saying i seem poisonous i don't mean
poisonous
it just seems like you're like no it's
no but on the upside
or that's the it's both that's kind of
the upside because i don't
right you don't have to i'm not stopping
yeah i don't have to like ah
um the downside is no one
offers me cocaine no one ever has and i
it's getting to the point where
it doesn't look like it's not happening
so
when dave seems approachable certain
once you're approachable and the amount
of
oh my god like you're bombing oh i mean
dave's a magnet he's a magnet he's a
magnet other
just wanna they just wanna chris they
don't
no but everybody wants to kind of be
funny with you guys
with community i just mean like let's
just say all comedians
especially headliners they wanna always
be they wanna do the thing that they
want when you meet mike tyson you want
to do this
exactly so you ah right put me in a
headlock
yeah when i met devo i met debo and he i
was like can we take a photo he's like
come on and then he put me in a headlock
i'm like i didn't need this
yeah it's a little much but i'm sure so
many people ask him
that's the move that they want so i just
do the thing yeah
um colin quinn
says when people are trying to be funny
around us
it's singing in the shower that's what
he calls it
it's like you're just trying to sing in
the shower like and you just like okay
it's their thing it is it really has
nothing to do yeah it's like
they just you just have sing yeah i get
it i sing in the shower
does do people do people ever try out
bits on you
people dm me that guy sent the pimp
sketch
that well that was good that was right
but there's no difference
right the only difference is that he
doesn't know what's good i mean you know
i mean he's like you could have
it seems good i bet he was like this
seems weirdly good
well a lot of people are that listener
that was like
fifteen thousand dollars yeah and then
like my sister did an intervention on me
and now i don't think it
um so days yeah dark days
uh it's uh you know what time it is i
think it's
it's uh it's you know to quote
the great philosopher will i don't have
to take this [ __ ]
i definitely don't take this [ __ ] you
don't i don't think that's
gonna do either and uh we got another
one in the books
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you